NARRATOR: Sebae is on a
mission to find his sister.
Without her help, Sebae will
struggle to keep her cubs alive
and may never rule again.
It's a hazardous journey
for the tiny youngsters.
Giants loom.
The mercury bubbles, and
danger lurks in every shadow.
They must stay close.
At last, a familiar
scent on the breeze.
[soft roar]
NARRATOR: Sebae's calls
go unanswered, leaving
a single terrifying question.
Is your sister still alive?
Filled with dread, Sebae fears
the worst for her sister,
but a tantalizing
scent lures Sebae on.
The cubs battle exhaustion
as their little legs struggle
to keep up.
Finally, the familiar call
she's been hoping to hear.
[soft roaring]
NARRATOR: Her beloved
sister safe and sound.
And she has cubs.
Two sisters, one family,
reunited at last.
Stronger together and
ready to build an empire.